There are 101 ways to make money online.
Now, most of them are fake, just
promoted by gurus trying to sell you
their courses. Which is why in today's
video, I'm sharing seven online hal side
hustles that you can start today to make
$100 a day. And I'll show you step by
step going from the easiest one to the
one that can make you the most money.
And to prove you that this works, I'll
even share screenshots of proof of
payments of me paying those people to do
those side hustles for me. And trust me,
they make a lot of money. Allah, let's
get into it. Starting with the first
one, copyrightiting. Copyrightiting is
simple. Copyrightiting is basically
writing in a way that makes people buy
the stuff that you're writing about.
That's it. You can write emails, ads,
script videos, any type of thing that
involves some sort of writing falls
under copyrighting. And here's a twist.
When 2025, we've got AI. So, we're not
going to write the emails to add the
scripts ourselves. We'll use AI to do
so. And to show you, I'll switch over to
my laptop. So, what you want to be doing
is logging in to clude.ai. And it's
amazing for writing. I'll show you
specifically how to tweak it in a way
that makes it right like crazy. What you
need to do is head over to this little
cross and create a new project. I'll
call it Ebu Copyriter. And I want you to
write emails in an amazing way to
convert readers into customers. Create
project for now. Let's try it out. I
have a $20 ebook teaching people how to
use Excel sheets and be very good with
it. Also very important to precise that
I don't want it to write like AI
otherwise going to mess everything up.
Don't write like AI use English below
level four. And because Clude is my guy,
I'm going to say, I trained AI live. It
took me literally 3 minutes and it's
printing an email off of two lines of
context. Now, this was good, but it's
just one email. So, how do we actually
make money from it? You have three ways
of doing it. Number one is selling
packages. Basically, because you're not
writing the email, you don't really care
about how many emails you have to write.
So, what you want to do is be
competitive on pricing and send them
bulk offers. Five emails for 100 bucks,
10 emails for 100 bucks, that's $10 an
email. But if it takes you two hours to
write those 10 emails, you basically
made $50 an hour as a side hustle from
an AI that you trained in 5 minutes.
This is insane. Now, emails was just the
start. You can actually use the same AI
with a few tweaks to write a lot more
than emails. For example, you can write
scripts. You can write YouTube scripts
or show scripts. You can feed the AI
some Mr. beast videos and say how
amazing he is at retention and all the
tactics that he's using in his scripts
and you can ask it to replicate those
for a specific guy. Send him 10 video
ideas and charge him 100 bucks. Same
thing. It's going to take you two to
five hours and you made 100 bucks in a
single day. Now, if scripts are not your
thing, you can do other things like ad.
You can script Facebook ads, Google ads
for people. Same thing. Look at great
people who are doing it, feed it to the
AI, give it the logic and replicate it
for other people. You can make PDFs or
guides for those people. Lastly, a thing
that I myself use is websites. My
websites, my funnels have copyrightiting
all the way. The titles, the headlines,
the sub headlines, how the customers are
going to think, how the customer
experience is going to be if we use this
sentence instead of this one. Same
thing. And lastly, once you close a few
clients, you might want to turn this
into a remote job. For example, when I
hire copyriters, I start by making them
write one to two simple emails. If
they're good, I make them write a five
to 10 email sequence. and if they're
really good, I'd offer them a full-time
job at my company. Now, to give you some
actual numbers, an email on average,
generally speaking, cost between $ 20
and $100. Now, if you're writing it with
AI, you can compete so much on volume.
And if you offer 10 emails for $150 and
they are really good, I guarantee you
you'll close clients. Now, in position
number two, we have a side hustle that
can make you a lot of money depending on
how available you are, and that is high
ticket sales. High ticket sales is
basically you taking sales calls over
the phone to sell people a certain
solution. Usually you get paid about 10%
of whatever you sell. You earn what you
kill. The products are on average $1,500
to $10,000 and the average close rate is
20%. So let's say you're taking five
calls per day to guarantee that you make
at least one sale every single day.
There are 1 hour calls. So that will
take you five hours and you're
guaranteed to make between 150 bucks and
a,000 bucks. And mainly there are three
requirements that you must have if you
want to really succeed in high ticket
sales. Specifically for these numbers
that I gave you, they are for the US
market. Don't worry, you can do high
ticket sales anywhere in the world, but
you would be selling to USA prospect,
American guys. Now, for those three
requirements, number one is being native
English or really good at English to the
point where we can't notice it because
you'll be speaking to native English
customers. They won't really like if you
have a very thick accent. Number two,
you need to be charismatic. I'm sorry,
sales is a game of energy. If you're not
slick, if you can't speak to people in a
great way and you can, you know, crack
some jokes and then get the mic in the
sale, high ticket sales is maybe not for
you. And lastly, you need to be super,
super resilient. Sales is a numbers
game. You need to be dialing the phone
all day speaking to people all the time.
And if you're not ready to have people
saying, "No, I don't want to buy your
thing. I hate you. Don't call me back."
And then you pick up the phone again and
you call someone else and you're super
happy and excited, then high ticket
sales again might not be for you. Now,
if you have those requirements, you're
going to make a lot of money with high
ticket sales. Now, if you heard
everything I mentioned about high ticket
sales, you were hyped, but then you
heard the requirements and you're like,
"I don't have it. There's no way."
Habibi, don't worry. I got you. You can
do appointment setting. Appointment
setting is basically high ticket sales
that pays a little bit less but you
don't need none of the requirements
because you can do what's called DM
setting. Basically you see those people
that speak on the phone all day and sell
to those people they are speaking to
them because they have appointments
because basically people agreed to speak
with them over the phone. And who set
those appointments? Appointment sellers.
So your job would be converting leads
people who are interested in a product
to people who are speaking over the
phone with your closers. And your job
with appointment setting is just to set
those leads that are interested in the
solution into appointments. And to do
so, you want to do three simple things.
And it starts with the qualification
part. You don't want to waste your
closest time because their time is very
valuable and they want to take as many
calls as possible. And since they only
eat what they kill, they get paid a
percentage. Then you must send them
qualified people. Otherwise, they're
going to hate you. The second thing you
want to do as an appointment setter
while you're talking to the prospect is
setting the expectations. It's basically
preparing the sale for the guy, making
it easier for your sales guy. You're
basically telling them, hey, this is the
solution. Here's how amazing it's going
to be. You prepare the ground, make it
easy for them, make sure they can afford
it, they also understand it makes sense,
everything's good, everything's ready.
You set the expectation on this call.
You're going to buy our product. And
lastly, if they are qualified, they have
the right expectation, they're ready to
move forward, then set the call. You're
simply going to send them a calendar
link for them to book a call at a time
that works for them so they can speak to
a closer and buy the product. If they
end up buying the product, you'll make
5% of the sale on average, which with
the same numbers that we had before, you
can make from $75 to $500 bucks per
sale. For sellers, I have some
appointment sellers on my team booking
11, 15 up to 20 calls per day. Imagine
how much you can make if you make $75,
which is the low end, $75 per call, and
you book 20 calls. Let's say half of
them end up closing. That's 750 bucks
for one single day of work. I'm telling
you, the side hustles are real. Do your
research, but I'm telling you,
appointment setting is the real game. I
personally have appointment setters that
work for me. And last month, I paid my
top appointment setter $6,000 cash. A
lot better. Now, enough talk about
selling stuff and taking people's money
and maybe you're more of a calm, chill
guy that just has a bit of creativity,
then video editing might be for you.
Video editing is a bit harder to learn
when you're a beginner. It takes some
time. The AI tools so far are not really
good for video editing. So you might
need to learn the skill by yourself. I
advise you to learn very very very
specific styles of video editing that
are in demand. And there are a few that
I can name. Now most editors say that
the market is saturated. But
realistically no market is saturated.
They're just saturated offers. And to
name a few, for example, everyone is
copying the Iman Gatsi style with fancy
animations and a bunch of effects. And
that's why you think video editing is
saturated cuz you're just doing what
everyone else is doing. Now, on the
other hand, if you become really good
at, for example, editing vlogs, of
course, make sure you don't use music,
but you can put find a great way to put
a climp in a nice order, make it feel
cinematic, etc. You're going to make a
bunch of money. To give you an idea, a
vlog cost between 200 and 500 bucks to
edit, and you can edit a vlog in two to
five days. So, again, making $100 a day.
Now, if you don't really like vlogs and
you're more of a chill guy, you like to
learn things as well as your work, you
might want to do documentaries, which is
basically educational content. This
video that you're watching right now
could fall under the category of
documentary content. It doesn't have any
music. You don't have to make excuses
and say, "Oh, my clients have music this
and that." You can just find the right
clients by either them being Muslim and
not using music, or you can find people
who just don't need music by default.
And lastly, with video editing, you can
do short form editing, specifically
repurposing, which is basically you
taking long- form YouTube videos from
creators and editing them for them to
post them on their social media, Tik
Tok, Instagram, and YouTube Shorts. Now,
for short form repurposing, there are so
many people that are doing it already,
but this market has so much money to be
made, and I'll show you how. First, be
really good at it and specifically at
retention on shorts because short form
is going to be on short form platforms
and people have a fried brain. So, if
you're not really good at making
retention edits, then you shouldn't do
short form. Now, how you can learn short
form retention is by watching on
YouTube. Again, plenty of tutorials.
There are people who are expert at
retention and you can learn how that
works. Now, once that you know how
retention works, you can go to YouTubers
and offer to repurpose their content on
other platforms. Also, if you want to go
further and really make an offer that's
really good, you can ask the clients to
add you to their YouTube studio.
Basically, this will allow you to check
the retention chart of the initial video
and you can see the spikes and where
people specifically put a like or where
people specifically watch a lot of the
video or put a comment on it or you can
go to the comment section and see when
people you know when they put the
timestamps and they say, "Oh, 4 minute
55 amazing advice." Then you take this
clip at 4 minute 55. You edit it in a
nice way where people can get the whole
context and repurpose that on other
social media. That would be an amazing
offer and I can tell you no one is doing
this. Now the fifth side hustle is
creating websites for people. Similarly,
we're in 2025. You can use AI to create
the websites. You don't need to code.
You don't need to do none of that. What
you want to do is make a special offer.
You don't always with a special. So,
what you want to be doing is you listing
the top 10, top 20 websites in a
specific industry and then you analyze
everything. You put all your research in
a Google doc and then you can go to
other people in this industry who have a
very bad website and offer to either
give them this doc and they pay you for
it which is most likely not the case.
People are going to be lazy. They want
you to do everything. So you can offer
to go and do the website for them. Now
specifically to make the website you
have two main ways. Number one is
finding someone on a freelancing website
like Upwork for example. You can pay
them 50 to 100 bucks for them to make
the website. Of course, once you find a
client, and the good thing about this is
that you'll be guaranteed a good quality
because you'll be getting someone that's
full-time's job is to make websites. So,
he'll be really good at making websites.
And also, you don't need experience in
design or any of that cuz he'll be
handling everything. You just need to
make the sales and broker the deals.
Now, the second option you have is
making the website yourself using AI.
This one is great because there's low
upfront cost. You don't really have to
pay for anything else than the software
that you're building the website on. You
can play the volume game and have a
bunch of websites made very quickly and
fulfill a lot of clients and have
cheaper prices and you also will have
fast delivery. Personally, if I start, I
might find someone else to do the
websites until I understand really well
how everything works. I get a reputation
built by having great websites. I can
sell the websites for three or 400
bucks. I'm not going to charge a lot of
money for this. I'll make sure the
websites are welld designigned, etc. And
then later on I can learn how to make
the websites myself if I want to save a
little bit of money. Or I can learn to
scale this specifically and start a web
design agency where I hire multiple
people to build websites for me and that
turns it into a full-time business. All
in all, if you sell a website for 300
bucks and you can sell five of them
every month, you make 1,500 bucks for
little side hustles where you're not
even doing the work. That's pretty good.
Side hustle number six is building
automations for businesses. Big
companies that have hundreds of
employees and hundreds of customers
cannot manage everything that they do
manually. They need automations for
things to be done automatically. For
example, an email to be sent when a new
customer comes in, a notification to be
received when a customer has a specific
request and needs a specific help. All
these little automations will save them
time and eventually save them money.
Zapier is a huge software for
automations. It basically interconnects
a bunch of softwares like Google Sheets,
Slack, Discord, emails, all these kind
of softwares and you can create what's
called zaps. A zap is basically a list
of actions that's going to be happening
once something triggers them. For
example, if you receive an email, then
send this message to one of the
employees and also start this other
sequence on the side. This can be very
timeconuming if someone is doing it
manually. So it can be automated with
Zapier. And your job as an automation
builder is to find time- conssuming
tasks and automate them with Zapier. For
example, remember what we spoke about
appointment setting when you want to set
the expectation, make sure people are
coming on board, knowing what they need
to buy, etc. Starting the sale before
you come in. Those things can be
automated to a certain degree. There are
plenty of tutorials on Zapier. There are
other softwares like make.com that can
also help you make those automations.
What you want to do here is play the
long-term game. You want to be really
good at automations. Start small with
$50, $100 automations and work your way
up until you can build really big stock
of automations and charge a lot for it.
Now, for the final and last side hustle,
I kept the best for the end. It is
influencer marketing. It's the one that
alle personally used myself and I made
most of my money from when I was a
beginner. Now, influencer marketing is
simple. You basically want to have
influencers get brand deals and you take
a commission on the deal. That's it. Now
disclaimer, you don't want to work with
any haram influencers. So anyone that
uses music, anyone that has like fitness
and shows his or some finances has a
clear nogo. Now the next thing once you
found a few influencers that you can
work with, you want to make sure they
have the right amount of followers so
that you can actually make money because
if they're not big enough for companies
to pay them, you're not going to make
any money. So you want to find people
between 200k and 500k followers. It's
very important because if the influencer
is too small, companies most of the time
won't really want to pay him. Now, on
average, the commission you can start
taking when you're a beginner are
between 15 and 20%, you don't want to
get greedy. You just want to start
making a little bit of money. Now, if
you agree with the influencer that any
deal you bring his way, he'll pay you a
cut of it 15 20%, then you can start
reaching out to companies, showing them
exactly why this influencer is amazing,
how amazing he is, and how he can gain
them a bunch more sales. Once they
accept, broker the deal, sign a contract
between the influencer and you, and sign
another contract between the brand and
you. Make sure they never get in touch
otherwise they'll just cut you off the
deal. And if you don't know how to
create a contract you can simply use a
software like docuign pendoc and create
an online contract between you and him.
You can ask about the legislations in
your country to make sure you're
respecting all the rules. Ask it also to
write up the contract. Get both people
to sign it and then you can go ahead
with the deal. Once the deal is done you
can get paid. When you're starting out,
you can expect to make a,000, 2,000
bucks a month working, you know, about
20 hours a week on the model. And you
can also scale it. If you have bigger
influencers, you can charge bigger
commissions, etc., etc. I actually have
data to show you how you can make
because I ran this model myself and I
coached a few guys on how to do this as
well. Now, you can see this brotheric
closed the deal for 12K, made about 3K
profitabic, which is about 25% of the
deal, and that is just through one deal.
Now, you have big people who close way
bigger deals, etc. But when you start
out, usually you're going to close
smaller deals like $1,200 on $400
profit, 3K deal with 1k profit, $1,200
with $800 profit. But these are very
small deals with very, very small
influences. Of course, later on you can
close some bigger deals, have some
madness. You can have some people that
are making up to 100k a month, etc.
That's way later down the line once you
have established your agency properly,
etc. If you want to start, simply be an
influencer agent. Find one or two
influencers that you actually want to
work with. help them find the right
brands and they'll help you make money
as well. So now that I showed you the
seven side hustles, you might ask me,
"But how am I going to close clients?"
Well, habibi, watch this next video. I
break down everything. Michael.